ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show audio only out of chicago uh
me and ben were reading lori lightfoot
uh the mayor her yelp
profile which is pretty
spectacular as you would imagine it
would be
everything lori lightfoot does
everything she wears
every expression she makes or doesn't
make
the pitch of her raspy voice
her turn of phrase
her kind of blank look the stare
when she just stares at a reporter
there's there's nothing about lori
lightfoot that i don't love
truly yeah i only want to talk to black
reporters
constantly with the race card constantly
with the gay sexuality card
the the the misogyny card i mean
again
a true batman villain a true
corrupt
goon
her local feuds
with burger king ed
the disgraced city council member
as they fight over a burger king
renovation
her winning in a runoff election against
some other idiot precwinkle yeah
whatever i mean
just the idea that this woman is is the
mayor of chicago it's like an it's a
real city right
so
there's something very interesting about
um
lori lightfoot to me
there there's something interesting that
somebody like her is able to climb the
ranks
to become the mayor of chicago
and and you found her yelp profile yeah
shout out to the person that sent me
this from when before she was mayor yes
this is from what was she doing then
oh interesting i wonder what she was
doing what was she doing we don't know
much about lori lightfoot pre-med yeah i
don't know did you just become the mayor
of chicago
there had to be some run-up to that
right yeah i'm curious as to what
what is what job do you have before you
become the mayor of chicago
like did she oh she worked in private
legal practice as a partner at mayor
brown and held various government
positions in chicago most notably she
served as president of the chicago
police board and chair of the chicago
police accountability task force wow so
they love her
dude we passed lightfoot's house the
cops are sitting outside
the cops look like they would not do
anything if you ran in there with a gun
like truly like the cops are sitting
there fighting the urge to run into the
house with a gun
the faces of the cops
sitting in the patrol cars outside lori
lightfoot's house they're basically like
hey man
do what you got to do i mean could there
be a less enthusiastic position
for those people
i mean they're not fans of lori now i
want you to read
because this is uh
this shows the type of person she is i
have never yelped anything in my life
like i've never
written a yelp review i've had
as we know on this show i've been quite
vocal about my many run-ins
with people
um i don't rat
i entertain
i talk about it on the show
i do not rat i do not make a written
report
of
a problem that i've had with a business
it's not it's not who i am
but there are lots of people who do
tons of them and they think it's okay
they think it's good
they think they're doing uh something
virtuous by warning other people about
the calamari at la bandanza
they have to make sure
that people know to avoid the [ __ ]
minestrone soup
at [ __ ] mateos
whatever
they're
committed
they will single out waiters at
waitresses by name
and i've read these reviews they it
fascinates me i did a comedy show once
for members of like i forget what it's
called the yelp 500 or something these
people have posted so many reviews on
yelp
so many reviews that they were like in
the elite tear of yelpers like sick
people right
and
they came to this comedy show uh or i
was booked on a comedy show for them
and as you would imagine uh the worst
audience in the world
judgmental
like people that were looking at the
glassware that they were serving the
drinks in like is this right
is this correct like miserable people
people who have nothing going on
people whose entire life is uh to be a
critic
uh
and and what's great about yelp is like
that's not your job
there's a great history of criticism
right in theater and in movies film and
in in dining you know
but but it's not your job
to be a critic so you've taken it upon
yourself to give yourself another job
you don't get paid for
which is to like pull revere
ride through the [ __ ]
uh woods telling people
what they should avoid
on this planet because god forbid
someone else gets duped now by the way
this is the reality nobody yelps to help
other people that's a fact there is not
one person who's ever written a yelp
review because they are concerned
that somebody else is going to have a
bad time at that establishment
that is the common defense of people who
write yelp reviews you're like well if i
don't tell people
[ __ ] to [ __ ] watch their back
at this particular denny's then who will
and it's like no no one cares
about
a stranger walking in and dealing with
the same rude incompetent service what
they are doing is they're doing it to
shame
to punish to call out because they know
companies read these reviews when i was
a tour guide we used to get reviews on
tripadvisor and we'd get bonuses if they
mentioned our name in a five-star review
and a lot of times they would mention my
name and they would be like um you know
he was horrible and then you would talk
to they would bring you in and then go
hey man we're getting these reviews
about you
and um
you know so
so
the idea that lori lightfoot
is a yelper is beautiful
worked in government her whole life
worked on the police accountability task
force so we know she loves
accountability okay
and there's something great about her
now this is a yelp review of when she
so this is from august 2017 and this is
a review of a party bus rental place a
limo and party
so lightfoot is going out on the town
is she married at that point yes because
she mentions her wife in this so
lightfoot is married and she's going out
on the town now we don't know to what do
we know
no it just says she's using the service
vip limousine and she gave them one star
she's using the vip limousine service in
chicago
and she's going out on the town and
she's unhappy with how this played out
laurie lightfoot
now mayor of chicago
very
unhappy with the service
being given to her by vip limousine
now
go into this i want you to read the
review because what's great about this
is the company does something that
companies rarely do
they rarely do this
they
call her
out
as not only a liar
okay but an abusive
person
and companies usually just write thanks
for the review we're gonna get to the
bottom of this you've seen with
companies right thank you so much
but
this is the
this is the reality
this company had had enough
they had had enough vip limo of chicago
all due respect calls lori lightfoot out
now ben is going to read this review
posted when
uh 2017. and here is lori
i would never use vip limo again
driver carlos showed up early for our
pickup a good sign right
turned out not to be so well i'm gonna
read it the way she wrote it turned out
not be so
carlos turned out
yes now
one of two things is happening
laurie
is
using the parlance of the streets
or
she's angrily typing which i think is
probably more likely lori is
enraged
typing this review
so so she's not not every word might not
be
but the general message is gonna come
through continue carlos shows up and
wants to use our bathroom a little
strange but fine
turns out he pisses on our toilet and
does not have the courtesy to put down
the toilet seats beginning of the end
we were going to the united center
carlos clearly has no idea who to get
there
he is totally reliant on a whacked gps
system that has him driving his huge
cadillac escalade stretch down extremely
narrow neighborhood streets going in a
route that made no sense i had to take
over and give him clear directions to
get to the expressway apparently that
was totally emasculating to him the
house says my gps says i should get off
at division off the expressway when we
are going much further south and west we
finally get there and he says he needs
two numbers for the return pickup
we had already given
the person paying oh wait we had already
given him one from my female spouse i
say i will just give him mine since i am
the person paying carlos says i need one
from the gentleman i am totally confused
and question this carlos explains to
this dumb female that he needs a number
from a guy because girls take too many
pictures and run down the battery on
their phone
my expression must have said something
because then he's then said trust me i
have been doing this 20 years i'm a
middle-aged woman not some dumb kid from
his misogynistic world view i of course
gave it to him and his response was to
rudely close the window divider while i
was talking
the guy was a complete a-hole stupid
terrible driver and a complete jerk on
top of it can't believe he is employed
and i would never use the service again
while he is laurie lightfoot
reviewing her trip to the united center
where she went with her spouse and an
unspecified gentleman to some event
very angry at carlos the limo driver
for not knowing what to do
she got mad at him for traveling down
suburban streets he pissed on the all of
the toys on the toilet
now
here
here is the
the business owner's response the turn
yeah well it's a turn yeah it's a real
turn here
because as let us all remember this
woman is in charge of one of the largest
cities in america yes this is a real
turn this is what they call
uh a reveal
if you're a fan of of uh
dramatic terminology
because we now find out
that laurie's character is called into
question
by the good people dare i say
good people
at vip limousine
in chicago remember this opened up
with lori very puzzled
about a man
showing up to use the bathroom
and then pissing
all over her seat
which she then called the beginning of
the end here is the statement from the
chicago
vip limo
one our driver did not use your bathroom
we checked the vehicle cameras and he
did not enter your home you had lots of
guests over and of them could have done
what you claim our wonderful driver
carlos did two
our drivers have gps systems that work
with current events and traffic chicago
austin often has festivals and we have
to work our way around them it is not
your place to tell him how to do his job
three
our drivers ask for a gentleman's phone
number actually because they don't ever
want to seem inappropriate asking for a
lady's phone number and you should
appreciate that carlos took the time to
ask for a backup phone number in case
you lose signal or battery again our
drivers know what they are doing and
have experience now here's the final
paragraph here
it seems to me the only person here who
is sexist my dear is you
i don't know where you come to your
conclusion that you were emasculating
him maybe you hoped you were your
language is horrendous and lewd just
your rant here make me feel embarrassed
for you also wow that's pretty insulting
that you refer to women who like to take
a lot of pics at their events as dumb
females
your driver arrived early he got you on
time and safely to your event your
credit card you provided on the contract
was declining we even let you use a
different credit card for payment which
is against our rules and you received an
upgraded vehicle twice the price of what
you paid without any up charge as a free
upgrade from our company wish i could
review customers like you
find something better to do with your
time and you should appreciate great
service when you receive it
wow
i mean you want to talk about
the smackdown
you want to talk about
a total
and utter embarrassment yeah can i am
just
enjoying picturing her face reading that
her expressionless face
reading this
which shuts her down
completely
the guy did not leave his car so this
this woman
made up
she made up yes
that he went into her house and pissed
on her seat
she just made that up she pulled that
out of thin air
if we were to believe these people which
i don't see any reason why not by the
way
it's the fact that's why they took
everything else with a grain of salt
they caught her
immediately in a lie
so then they go well now we're just
because that was one of the harshest
responses i have ever seen a company
give
so you know that they are confident that
they are in the right
they are confident that they're 100 in
the right
i have never seen
a statement from a company delivered
with such venom
as as the the correction
to lori lightfoot's slander
you know who this person is like you
know who laurie is she's um
you know you want to talk about a
bureaucrat
you want to talk about uh
uh uh somebody who
is
pushy
rude
demanding
likes getting people in trouble
likes calling people out
does not like to be called out does not
like to be responsible for their own
behavior
invents versions
of interactions that did not happen
as long as the person looks horrible
likes people getting fired likes people
getting shamed likes people losing money
this is the type of person who we're
dealing with truly and i couldn't love
her more
i couldn't feel more
of an affection for this woman and a
gratitude that she's on the planet
because my entertainment is so important
to me because the world is
is is really trite
and yet this is great now yes
if i was someone who lived in one of
these places in chicago that was you
know suffering from inordinately and i
mean to say inordinately but high rates
of homicide uh the city is falling apart
sure not her fault but she's clearly not
helping sure i would maybe find it less
humorous but the fact that i don't live
anywhere near her
and i can just i don't i have there's no
i don't deal with any of the
repercussions from her personal behavior
which is as we've seen atrocious
to me
she's just a very entertaining person
the ill-fitting suits the fedoras the
blank stare
you know the dancing she's like on
camera dancing with people she has no
conscience
lori lightfoot
and that is what i like about her she
will lie about a limo driver and say he
pissed in her house to get him fired she
has no conscience it is what allows her
to dance as people are getting shot
children getting shot in the face she
dances she has no conscience she's a
true villain
truly all the things we find abominable
in the world abhorrent all of the the
personality types we want to avoid the
nanny the rat
the karen
the
the person who you know
keeps the receipts and tries to
you know
uh
you know get somebody fired
embarrass somebody
this is this is who she is and this is
how she runs chicago a petty vindictive
chief executive who will not take any
blame similar to trump she has a lot of
trump has qualities the leaders are
somewhat similar
the leaders i wonder if there's
something to that
at the end of america the leaders have
similar qualities they are craven
narcissists without they refuse to take
any responsibility and they live in a
version of reality that they find uh
best but they do not
uh as chris hedges says they are
disconnected from reality like all of
these people that are running these big
corrupt machines that are failing like
chicago
are unwilling to live in reality because
reality is not fun
reality is not fun and you can see it in
one yelp review what's fascinating is
that in one yelp review you can get a
glimpse of the type of person can you
imagine the trump yelp reviews that he
would have written oh yeah had that been
around the credit card declining would
be there too the same review the thing
the things that he would do and say
because that's you know an attribute of
their personalities you know
it's perhaps why they succeed
it's perhaps why they succeed because
what this what what it allows them to do
is they are in their mind they have a
god complex
and anyone that is not worshiping them
at any moment
has to be thrown under the bus
you saw trump did it with a lot of his
underlings he did it with a lot of his
supporters
lightfoot does it with everybody i'm
sure it's a common theme amongst this
like personality type but again
a huge fan of her
uh and i wish her the best
because
nothing to me is better
than
someone who wears
baggy pants like
hers
her pants don't fit
and she's standing there you got to get
that photo up of her if you haven't seen
her and she's just standing there
staring blankly
you know the pant leg is going under the
heel of the shoe yeah she's walking on
her pants yes for so long yes that is
what
a goon does that is what a villain does
it it is it is so important as a villain
uh as a troll and she is a troll of the
highest order
her lack of care
about her appearance
is because again
she doesn't live in reality
she's living in a world where the pants
fit
she's living in a world where they're
turning the corner on the shootings
she's living in a world where the limo
driver pissed all over her couch
and and that world has elected her mayor
of chicago
so why not just like trump he became the
president why not
right
reality
really in many cases is an obstacle
to what you want to do and where you
want to go
and a lot of these people have figured
that out it's not gonna get better
people are now wearing n95 masks in west
coast just because of the wildfire smoke
god bless anyone buying a home in l.a
god bless you
as you've said you believe that a lot of
this is going to get bad and the west
coast
and parts of the south are just going to
become uninhabitable uninhabitable whoa
yeah when
uh really by like 20 80. who says just
things i read from top it's gonna get
bad yeah it's gonna get bad
people are gonna go to wisconsin up to
the northeast places like that parts of
montana a little bit but and then canada
canada well that's what we're trying to
do what we're trying to do is is find a
place to just keep our head above water
leaving austin texas very soon our long
national nightmare is over
you saw the the movers come you watch
the movers come
and take the furniture out they took it
out emotional
yeah how uh about how many months
and again i'll be there uh through the
end of the year uh on and off february
through i guess october i guess just
february when i first arrived in austin
there was a biblical snowstorm biblical
that knocked out power
people couldn't get food
certain parts of the city had no clean
water
a smarter man would have seen that as a
sign
a smarter man but tim dillon not always
intelligent
has a lot of heart but not always
thinking um but there was a part of me
that did uh believe that potentially
this was a sign
that
all was not going to be well
when i'm driving through texas in a
snowstorm
first in over 100 years
i should have maybe said to myself
is this a sign
telling me that this is not going to
work out and we tried we gave it our all
and and
and i didn't i didn't try that hard
because my all is in that much
my all is not that much i'm
36 years old i'm and i know that people
are that's young and
it's not
here's the deal it's really not
if you are my age let me tell you
something you do not have your whole
life ahead of you that is a lie
in fact you never have your whole life
ahead of you really no matter what age
you are because no one knows when it's
over so the idea that when somebody goes
you have your whole life ahead of you
you can't live thinking that you don't
have your whole life ahead of you 36 you
have to know what you like and know what
you can stand and know what you can
tolerate if at 36 you are still on the
fence about anything you're insane
if you don't know your sexuality if you
don't know your gender if you don't know
what makes you come if you don't know
what kind of movies you like if you
don't know whether you like to read a
book at night or go get coked out and
[ __ ] on a pool table you don't know
who you are at 36 years old you're
probably not gonna find out and you know
what you don't want to
god forbid you find out who you are at
36 it may terrify you you should have an
idea 36 what kind of person are you are
you a coffee house person or do you want
to see them blown up i'm the latter
does laurie lightfoot
represent positive change to you
you should know this
are you a person who leaves a yelp
review and lies about a limo driver to
try to get him fired
are you getting in skirmishes with uber
drivers at 36 is that who you are are
you in the closet lying to people about
who you [ __ ] because you're embarrassed
about the things you like and you're
afraid about people finding out who you
truly are because you may get less
invites to the game or whatever and i'm
not saying anyone has to come out but
but are you that per cause you know who
you are at 36 i'm too old to pretend
that i can [ __ ] make it work it will
not work
nothing not a friendship i know
i somebody flew in to hang out with us
a month ago
and they got in the car i don't even
hate this person but i don't like them
they were a younger person
not sexual thing not anything
just a dude to hang out
i ended up pulling over in a parking lot
making up some excuse and putting this
person out of my car
it was about under an hour we had spent
under an hour with them maybe an hour i
am done
letting things go is my point they flew
from florida from miami to new york to
hang out with us
after an hour of their behavior
and their antics i decided
that it was time
to move on
as you get older
everything's about brevity you got it's
got to be quick you gotta know and
you're gonna you cannot
suffer
endlessly there's no value in that
you know it it it's about knowing what's
going on and moving the [ __ ] on
and that's the thing you know i found
myself in austin i found myself going i
can do it i can figure it out i can i
can adapt i'm not adaptable really i've
i've earned the right er by the way
here's a f i'm going full [ __ ]
motivation today
earn and i want you to look at your
lover partner friend mother father and
go if you've i have earned the right to
not be adaptable
earn that right
earn the right to not be adaptable i am
not adaptable i saw someone
say to their boyfriend once they said
you're so adaptable i thought that was
the biggest insult i had ever heard in
my life i i wished he turned around and
cracked her in the mouth and i'm against
domestic violence so you can only in
most cases
some half half of the cases i'm against
it a good half of the time i think it's
wrong but the point is
that you know
that uh that is an insult adaptable as
an insult malleable is an insult
earn the right to draw a line in the
sand and say no thank you i don't want
to go there i don't like them
i don't want to deal with it i was
laying in bed with covert it was a mild
case you know because i was vaccinated
but really because i got the regeneron
whatever everyone i know who's
vaccinated has covered and is dying but
whatever i guess that's what was
supposed to happen
every day they they they literally tell
you less and less to expect from the
vaccine like you're like i have it i
probably won't get it right they're like
oh no you'll get it yeah but i won't get
sick oh you'll get sick yeah but i won't
die you'll probably die
it's and i'm not saying let's not get it
or whatever but let's be honest this
hasn't worked out ideally can we be
honest and say that the vaccine has not
been ideal can we say it hasn't been
ideal
i can smell half of what i used to smell
i'm three weeks out i don't know that
the rest is coming back can we can we
just say
that it's not been ideal and yes does it
keep you from dying the numbers say that
and i hope that's true
i hope it's true
but
we can admit
that we had hoped for more with the
biden presidency can we admit that
perhaps we had hoped for more
it's not inspiring
it's not an inspiring presidency is it
that this dementia patient comes out now
i'm for the afghanistan withdrawal we
should have done it a long [ __ ] time
ago um but when you see this spell
skin and bones rag this flesh suit
walking out to deliver remarks after
these servicemen have been tragically
killed can we say that it's just not
ideal
is that allowed
is it allowed to recognize imperfections
when they are
obvious to us
so at 36
i've earned the right and i hope you
have earned the right to not be
adaptable
to have things you don't like i don't
like ethiopian food
and i and it has nothing to do
with
uh
i've tried it
i think i love other types of african
food i don't like the squishiness of it
and i'm sure there's ethiopian food
that's not squishy i but i don't care so
don't email me
but the the squishiness of it the idea
that everything's kind of like some type
of applesauce
i don't like it
and i don't need to prove a point by
going to an ethiopian restaurant i know
i'm not racist
so
i don't need to do it
it's not for me i love goat
give me goats
but
i know what i like there there's got to
be a point
where you you say to yourself i can't
function
uh in a city like austin texas which is
a schizophrenic place
a place full of like
the worst kind of
red state morons
and the worst kind of liberal it's a
collision
of the biggest morons that you've ever
met
near due wells
c-list
d-list except for like rogan and musk
it's
everyone's psychotic everyone you meet
whether it's in the tech space or
anything has a big idea
and a big dream it's nice that new york
and la have beaten the dreams out of
people beating the beat and beating them
out
so the people you meet are not
completely crazy when you talk to people
in austin they have wide-eyed things
they go i'm going to start my own city
and you go okay thank you and you just
back away slowly keeping them in your
view
in case they get physically
unpredictable
there's something about the wide-eyed
nature of austin that reminds you of
brooklyn circa 2012 one of the worst
places ever in history wide-eyed people
myself i was one of them
who believed that stand-up comedy was
medicine
and it was going to save and help me
and all the people i had around me were
going to have that beautiful experience
it was going to be transcendent and we
were going to live and love and laugh
forever well it doesn't work close your
eyes
austin's going to be nothing but a [ __ ]
la that smells like pork chops
and your dreams are the things that will
eventually tie a noose around your neck
and hang you from the tree
and the sooner you get to that position
the smarter you'll be don't be adaptable
don't be adaptable i've earned the right
bluetooth everybody bluetooth unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but enjoyable tablets at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night so
you can plan ahead or just be ready
whenever the best part is all done
online blue chew helps give you the
confidence in the bedroom
blue truce tablets are made in the usa
and prepared to ship directly to your
door in a discreet package okay
it is great everybody loves bluetooth
whether or not you even have a penis
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help
they've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code td at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew promo code td to receive your
first month free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank blue chew for
sponsoring the podcast it's so important
to have blue chew around whenever you
need it for friends family whatever it's
beautiful not that you're gonna have sex
with your friends and family but who
knows i don't know what the laws are
where you live the point is
that
as long as everyone's of age and
consenting you should be able to have
sex with your family
truly
incest is like the final taboo
blue chew
keeps you got to keep your hair one of
my good friends is using this and they
love it
keeps offers a simple stress free way to
keep your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home low
cost treatments start at 10 per month it
keeps offers generic versions discrete
packaging and proven results keebs has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors prevention is key treatments
can take four to six months to see
results so act fast this is a great way
to keep the hair you have on your head
i'm telling you it's important if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon to receive your
free first month
of treatment free first month that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon to
get your first month free i'm telling
you one of my friends uses this service
really likes it and he's noticed a
difference he stopped losing his hair
and he's really excited about that
um that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon
spike lee
sadly
genius acting a little adaptable doing a
911 documentary on what on hbo hbo hbo
911 four part series was going to
include some 911
skeptics people that are skeptical of
the official narrative specifically the
conspiracy group architects and
engineers for 9 11 truth
yes
now
what happened ben you've been following
this did the media have a cow so two
days ago in the new york times this was
the end of the interview where he says
uh they say the last step and by the way
this isn't out if you're wondering why
you haven't seen this members of the
media have have seen episodes already so
the uh journalist says the last episode
of this series devotes a lot of time to
questioning how and why the towers fell
you interviewed several members of the
conspiracy group architects and
engineers for 9 11 truth why did you
want to include their perspective he
said because i still don't i mean i got
questions and i hope that maybe the
legacy of this documentary is that
congress holds a hearing a congressional
hearing about 911. and he says you don't
buy the official explanations and spike
says the amount of heat that it takes to
make steel melt that temperature is not
reached and then the juxtaposition of
the way building 7 fell to the ground
when you put it next to other building
collapses that were demolitions it's
like you're looking at the same thing
but people going to make up their own
mind my approach is put the information
in the movie and let people decide for
themselves i respect the intelligence of
the audience and then the journalist
says this right but you don't say make
up your own mind about whether or not
the vaccine is poison or make up your
own mind about whether joe biden was
legitimately elected spike says people
are going to think what they think
regardless i'm not dancing around your
question people are going to think what
they think people have called me a
racist for do the right thing people
said in mo betta blues i was
anti-semitic she's got to have it that i
was a misogynist people are going to
just think what they think and you know
what i'm still here going on four
decades of filmmaking and i respect that
and i respect his thing of like why are
you gonna do a documentary about 911
without putting in by the way these are
not
see this is what gaslighting is and i
hate that word i hate the new
terminology right but isn't gaslighting
the type of thing where you're made to
feel insane yes exactly right so when
you ask these questions that are
realistic logical questions like hey
building seven what's up with that
okay normal rational questions going
this doesn't look like anything except
it looks like a demolition it doesn't
look like anything that's ever happened
in the way that a fire is taking
something out when you ask that very
rational question you are gaslighted
you're made to believe that you were
insane you go oh well what about the
vaccine what about biden you think we
landed on the moon oh yeah what are you
one of those guys our lizard people live
underground huh you know i didn't say
any of that i'm simply asking a [ __ ]
question because i have senses i have
eyes and ears and it seems [ __ ] weird
that's all isn't it weird if you told
someone it was weird that 15 hijackers
from saudi arabia attacked the the
biggest military power ever seamlessly
and very successfully and then that
military power went in on to invade iraq
and afghanistan and countries really
didn't have much to do with this and
this was all directed by osama bin laden
and we censored 17 pages in the 911
report that were damaging to our
our ally saudi arabia and uh the 911
commission chair said we were set up to
fail and we didn't have the resources
and the information that we wanted and
the president would only testify with
the vice president in a like
ventriloquism session that they had in
front of this commission if you were to
take all of that and if knowing what we
know about the government and what
they're what they've done and what
they're capable of to even like spike
lee a brilliant director a smart guy a
guy who understands
questions
that's what art is great art
he understands why can i ask this
question we don't know what the answer
is we don't know where it's going to go
when you start writing a novel you don't
always know the end
you don't know you the work grows it
changes it evolves why can't we ask the
questions when people are shutting down
the questions
it's a whole new level of a problem
the answers are one thing you can fight
about answers but if you shut down the
questions you can't even get to the
answers so the idea that there's a
coordinated attempt to smear
spike lee for including a small what
half hour it was a half hour of the last
episode which by the way 24 hours later
after this article after the media
firestorm yeah what happens tell us so
as it stands now this journalist says
they went and watched the
hbo sent out an email to critics
thursday announcing that the screener
site was updated with the final edited
picture as it stands now episode 4
appears to be exactly 30 minutes shorter
than the original version that i watched
on monday coming in at 90 minutes long
instead of two hours indeed the entire
segment on the 911 conspiracy group and
all apparent references to the group
appear to have been excised so it's gone
he just he took it out a day later and
it's the pressure it's the pressure that
comes from the top people go don't hey
we don't want you don't want
[Music]
now in fairness i did not see the 30
minutes
and it would be hilarious
if the 30 minutes was just him like
talking to louis farrakhan about the
jews and hbo goes i gotta be honest with
you
lewis farkas like when the jews put the
fuses in the buildings
and
i understand that that could be
offensive
absent fat
absent that
i imagine it was an exploration of of
people's uh
skepticism about the official narrative
which is now completely
amputated completely removed from the
final
product the finished product
it sucks so now you have an eight hour
documentary about 9 11 they don't
mention anything about the conspiracy
well sure i think you know i was looking
to ray about it earlier i said what is
the percentage of people
who believe the official story of 9 11.
i don't by the way when i say that and i
want you to listen to this you're in
your car
or you're on a treadmill
well it's my fans you're in your car
and whatever no we have healthy fans and
whatever it is
you're listening to this i am not saying
do you believe the bush administration
did 9 11.
i'm not saying do you believe that for
knowledge of 9 11 by the way
not the worst question
what i'm saying
is do you believe
that you know and possess all of the
relevant knowledge about the 9 11
attacks do you believe that i don't
very few people i know believe that i'm
talking about conservative rara patriot
people that i know
okay
are now
in the last few years
even before trump
coming to a uncomfortable conclusion
that they don't really know
what happened
in
with the clarity that they would like
that's all
and
most people
are
i believe willing
and have an open mind
about the length to which elements of
our government will go
to cover up
criminal
evil behavior
jeffrey epstein
prime example that is evil criminal
behavior
um
and it's it covered up
so the links of which people will go to
cover up the video i don't know what
happened
i've talked to very smart people that
believe the mainstream narrative
have a lot of questions i will put
myself in the camp that has questions
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with that
and i think that
didn't woody harrelson wasn't he gonna
do something with this too yes i
actually have this pulled up
what did woody cause i think woody
harrelson
as well had some
uh
ideas or reservations yeah so uh yeah
this because this is an article i found
that celebrities that don't buy uh that
are into construction we just won't call
her back on the show uh yeah just put
her up next
year hey listen you're on once you're on
the podcast we're doing audio only
tell everyone about your new show cause
we we loved it i listened to
about 45 of the first episode give it a
little plug uh awakening od is a guide
to the matrix from an eight-dimensional
uh galactic being who is assigned to
earth and doesn't want to be here
i loved it i love how good you are at
talking this is jessa reed
and the podcast is called awakening
and she's insanely good at conveying
complex ideas
thank you thank you very much i mean
that's the fact i'm just sitting in the
baby's room talking about 911 in my
airbnb
which i can't rent cause i'm not allowed
on airbnb
they let you back in airbnb they
absolutely did not we use another
account
i'm banned forever i'm public enemy
number one
airbnb so i'm sitting in this baby's
room talking about 9 11.
and this is my career this is my career
people don't they think i'm doing well
monetarily i am but my career like it
would be nice to walk on a red carpet
you know
i'm in a baby's room talking about
building seven it's not as glamorous as
it seems
why why are you in a baby's room because
it is the best um what ben uh acoustics
acoustics because it's carpeted
has been with you yes
hi ben hey jessa we ben you lot you
loved the episode too yes jessa we both
listened i i loved it i i love your
stuff about aliens and interdimensional
stuff and i i you i you make astrology
and all that stuff exciting to me it's
it's
it's the podcast if you're into that
stuff but you want somebody who's got a
very funny dry
take on things it's very funny and
you're not
like one of these white chicks who you
want when you hear them talk you want to
kill
yourself uh thank you thank you very
much yeah it's uh consciousness for
people that hate the new age movement
i love it
i love it well listen we gotta finish
this episode i'll call you later
all right all right thanks babe
jessica reid check that podcast out
awakening
on youtube and
other podcast platforms but again
i'm not adaptable at this point in my in
my career well i guess for the right
amount of money if you give me a hundred
million dollars here's why i will stop
talking about 911. okay do you want to
know this and i want my audience to
understand this and what's the number
what's the number of money
i don't know what'd i say 100 million i
think so yeah probably eight million
dollars
my talking about it has done nothing
do you understand
it hasn't
congress is not having a hearing no one
gives a [ __ ] right in fact people are
annoyed when you bring 911 up i don't
even mean truthers people are just like
hey man we're over it right yeah yeah so
for like
i don't know three million dollars
i'll shut up about it
for 20 million dollars i will come on
the show and talk about why the official
story makes sense i'll start another
podcast called 911 did happen
the way they said
for 20 million dollars and i will every
episode
through gritting my teeth and rolling my
eyes
or i'll just really believe it like i'll
relapse yeah yeah really so now what is
woody harrelson trying to do
okay so uh he was gonna make a movie it
says uh because this is an article that
says celebrities that believe in
conspiracy theories here's the 9 11
section it says martin sheen's son
charlie sheen was reportedly set to star
with woody harrelson in a movie called
september mourn which charlie sheen with
charlie sheen and i believe this was
back in 2012 or so when it said it
questioned the official narrative behind
911 but the movie never materialized and
then charlie sheen went on alex jones i
missed this did you see him going alex i
believe i saw that i didn't realize
there was going to be a movie about it
with charlie sheen that sounds [ __ ]
awesome
and martin sheen's a truth or two did
you know that probably
by the way i don't think the movie would
have accomplished the movie probably
hurt the truth or movement
absolutely
charlie sheen starring in a truther
movie directed by woody harrelson
is almost as close to a cia op as you
get
because people would have walked out of
that theater and went i guess the
government is right
you know
but
i still would have liked to see it right
yeah it would have been great you know
what i mean
that's like lori lightfoot doing like
pro-vaccine stuff you go do you want
people to get it or not because no one
is being convinced by this goon
can you get the thing up where i we
played it on a patreon we won't play it
but it's her she has a great psa
about the vaccine oh yeah yeah we played
it on the pitch
i don't know man all i'm saying is that
there is a theme to the episode i think
and part of the theme is
there is a level
uh of which you realize unfortunately
that truly nothing matters
and then you have two choices
one is to develop a strict personal code
of ethics of which you follow
somewhat religiously it could include
hard work honesty
integrity
whatever
or none of the above it could include
none of that in fact it could be the
opposite it could include lying
manipulation and sloth but as long as
it's your personal code it is what will
get you through the other thing to do
when you realize that nothing really
means anything is to join isis
or some type of death cult right
there's no real middle ground
if you have the realization that things
don't mean much
donald trump had a great great quote
about the indian earthquake this is what
allows him to be him and he said
something anna anna from red scare
had tweeted it or put it on instagram
where he was basically like
can't worry about anything you worry
about things and then 400 people die in
an earthquake in india it doesn't matter
with some
some approximation of that
and
he's right to a degree right like you
know kurt vonnegut said the most
successful people
are sociopaths because they're
constantly doing they're never thinking
about the consequences you go do this do
that
the lord lightfoots yeah lie about the
guy yeah he came in he pissed all over
the kitchen fire him
well think about him his family
you don't think about the fact that they
have cameras in a car that could tell he
didn't [ __ ] leave now you look like
an idiot you know you're not even
looking out for yourself
the real old-school gangsters like hw or
joe kennedy or any of that you know they
try to look out for themselves too
you know
but
it's very hard for people like lightfoot
because they're so impulsive and
reckless
and trump to a degree too like the new
breed of leader
uh
it's very interesting seeing what
happens to them where they inevitably
end up
of course lori
does not have near the talent
that donald does
but they share
some of the same things when does spike
lee's documentary come out it looks like
the first episode is out already and
then i guess they'll probably release
some week by week
looks like i want to see the lost
footage
of the spike lee documentary and i hope
it was truly offensive
because it's all gone i hope it was the
most offensive thing i hope it was spike
lee
and louis farrakhan
just talking about jews for 30 minutes
to a point where hbo goes we're
uncomfortable
because if it was anything other than
that i think it should be in the
documentary
you know
but i just you know
what if 30 minutes is just so unhinged
spike lee you're talking about flat
earth
he's just like listen
we live on a disc
hbo's like wait a minute this doesn't
seem to has nothing to do with 9 11.
a few decades ago private citizens used
to be largely that private
what's changed the internet ben uses
this
so important that you have a vpn
all the things you browse search for
watch tweeted all the data is crawled
through collected and aggregated by
third parties in a permanent public
record your record having your private
life exposed to others to see
uh that was something once only
celebrities worried about but now it's
happening to everybody so you need
expressvpn
okay
expressvpn is great it is a virtual
private network scrambles your ip
address so people don't know where you
are searching from
it's so important data harvesters use
your ip to uniquely identify you and
your location but expressvpn the
connection gets rerouted to an encrypted
server and my ip address is masked every
time i turn expressvpn on i'm giving a
random ip address shared by other
expressvpn customers that makes it more
difficult for third parties to identify
me and harvest my data and the best part
is how easy expressvpn is to use no
matter what device you're on phone
laptop smart tv all you have to do
is tap one button to get protected so if
you like me believe you're done is your
business secure yourself with number one
rated vpn on the market expressvpn.com
tim dillon and get three extra months
for free that's expressvpn.com tim
dillon uh and get three extra months for
free expressvpn.com
i'll tell you is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own license
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional counseling done securely
online there's a broad range of
expertise available that may not be
locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly or video phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit around in
an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they can make it
easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today visit their
website and read their testimonials that
are posted daily
that's better help help
dot com tim d and join over the 1
million people who've taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people are choosing better help in all
50 states that they're recruiting more
counselors all the time
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and tim dylan show listeners get 10
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com tim d it's been fun uh
being back out on the road post uh
having covered and when i had kova this
is what i was trying to say before when
you have covered at 36 you go yeah i
could drop dead right i could die and
and statistically you know probably with
the vaccine you won't or whatever is
what they say
but any anything like that you know i
could die
when you're laying there in bed going
this could take a turn for the worst and
i could
die
you start realizing the value of
existing
and how many people are on this planet
but don't exist
you know what i mean like
they don't exist
and
they don't exist it's it's
it's not because they shouldn't
or they don't have the value as human
beings they don't allow themselves to
exist they don't allow themselves to be
the person
that
they potentially could be if they had a
little bit of guts
a little bit of balls but even beyond
that if they just stop giving a [ __ ]
stop adapting stop pretending you like
things you don't stop pretending things
make sense to you when they don't
when things don't make sense go that
doesn't make sense to me
yes it'll upset people probably
depending on what you're saying doesn't
make sense
if it's a configuration of hors
d'oeuvres it might not upset people when
it's 9 11 it will
but that's okay
but you go because you could drop dead
tomorrow and would you want to be
remembered for something or would you
want people to say like that person
really was like a person like that
[ __ ] you were a defined
person you existed you had beliefs and
thoughts and you you you you came to
them
through a journey and some of them
evolved and changed but you stuck to
them
you weren't completely wish you i
respect and let me be careful about how
i say this
can i be careful about how i say this
who do you respect more
your aunt who's on another diet every
week
or a fat pig
shoving a hoagie down their throat
who do you respect more
your friend who started reading about
politics 16 minutes ago
and is now an expert on international
relations or the taliban
who do you respect more
somebody
who's
trying
to be
something that everybody will like
or lori lightfoot
a demon
sent to earth from hell
i know
i know who i respect
you can decide who you respect
there's nothing worse than like somebody
who's wishy washy and i i've changed my
mind there's nothing wrong with changing
your mind but it comes from a core idea
of
what is and isn't real
we're barely talking about right and
wrong anymore we're talking about
reality
and that's the other thing people don't
realize it's not even a right and wrong
paradigm it's reality or
wherever you are
whatever planet you're on
it's very very interesting but we hope
you come see us live uk shows
are going to be announced soon
so everybody who's a fan in the united
kingdom
scotland
ireland
the uk
we may be coming hopefully as soon as
january
wouldn't that be
amazing
if you're coming as soon as january
wouldn't this be amazing
we don't know yet we're trying
and
that is happening the beacon theater in
new york city is almost sold out and i
will say this this is kind of wild right
i usually don't do the emotional like
the journey is so beautiful because i
just don't do that right i don't do that
i don't i don't tell you to vote i don't
tell you to get vaccinated i don't tell
you to be a good father i don't tell you
to be a good friend i don't tell you to
watch your children i don't tell you to
read i don't tell you to have interest i
don't tell you to be honest i don't tell
you to respect the cops i don't tell you
to respect criminals i don't tell you to
get a good job and provide for your
family i don't tell you to finish
college i don't tell you not to do drugs
i don't tell you not to drink i don't
tell you to do drugs i don't tell you to
drink i don't tell you to get a rescue
dog i don't tell you to abuse animals i
don't tell you to donate money to abused
animal shelters
the reason i don't do any of that is i
don't give a [ __ ]
you
understand you're gonna do what you do
anyway okay
that's what people have always done
people make a lot of money telling you
what to do and that's great and you keep
giving them that money because money's
got to go somewhere but my only interest
is making you laugh and occasionally
think so i tend not to get on some big
like you can do it just believe and try
and goon you
because you probably can't do it
whatever it is right the reason you
think you can do it is because you're
insane you're either on too many or not
enough drugs
but there are things you can do and i
don't know what they are so i can't give
a vague blanket garyvee statement say
you can do it that might mean kidnapping
a child i don't know what's in your head
you can do it some guy goes great they
run into a school with an uzi i don't
want that on my conscience so you see
how i keep but i will say i will just
say that it is cool to start doing
comedy
11 years ago in a coffee house in long
island new york and to sell out the
beacon theater that is really cool
i'm not gonna make any type of you know
i'm not going to thank all of you
because you had nothing to do with it
you understand
do you understand
okay
you have anything to do with it
ben does
but you don't you have something to do
with it in a tangential way sure
and i love comics and god bless and
listen if there's so many more
inspirational motivational better like i
get it and am i grateful that you buy
tickets to my show yes but i want to
make you laugh
if i thank you too much i feel like i
don't have to do my job i have a job to
do and i try to do it
and i think our interaction makes sense
you give me money i give you content you
think it's funny we move on maybe we
meet each other
in real life maybe you come to my show
and you're good looking and you send me
a picture of yourself
and then you say you don't want to hook
up with me uh but you'd like [ __ ] my
opener and then i'm like wait what
this isn't the way it works
you know
also come out of the closet no one cares
you're 24. anyway point is this
what i'm saying is that it is cool
that i i get to do that i feel lucky
that i get to do it obviously whatever
there's a lot of work that goes into it
but it's a cool thing if you guys want
to be there
and there will be no moment in the show
where there's any like emotional like i
just wanna say
that you gave me the shut up
shut up
in a few years i'm gonna end up like
brandishing a gun in a diner
how silly will it look
that that's my ultimate inevitable end
me getting emo at the beacon theater and
telling everyone i love them when i just
know because i'm irish and because i am
me that there is very little chance i
make it out of this without brandishing
a gun at a diner
and i'd rather people go back to the
earlier things i've done and said he had
such self-awareness he even predicted
that he would brandish a weapon in an
eatery and he was right
you see it's about consistency but if
you want to be
a part of the beacon theater audience
we're doing a great show there there
aren't a lot of tickets sold out i mean
there's not a lot of tickets left which
is pretty damn cool that whatever we're
doing here is resonating with people
that's cool
but i'm not going to be like you know
a whole new uh you know it's it's fine i
everyone on youtube does that every
social media person
is and i watch you know some of these
social media guides and then we're like
it's just me and you forever we built
this forever it's like all these social
media you know people and i just feel
like i just want to tell all of you
listening right now we did not build
this together
i don't even know who you are
truly
and i think that's why you listen to
this show
because i think you're fed up with
people you don't know
telling you that you built something
with them and you did something together
we did very little together
very little together
but we have a good interaction we have a
fair interaction it's fair
it's fair i give you something you give
me something there's fairness
to it and i think that that is
i think that's all we can ask for
that's all we can ask for you know uh
but this is what it is folks this is
where we're at we're we're lucky enough
to do some really really cool [ __ ] and i
think the beacon theater is maybe one of
the coolest things i've done i don't
know
i don't know maybe rogan alex jones
might beat it to be honest
it's just because of the medium though
30 million people i mean that's just big
right
the b can you know be 2 600
self-entitled new york [ __ ]
you know i'm excited about it i just
let's be honest
i have to call a spade a spade i just
wish the beacon theater was located in
like you know i don't know
rochester or some you know some hellish
i just need these upper west side [ __ ]
to walk in and be like i don't really
whatever
it's fine i get it
just be a bunch of people at you know
what diners afterwards going like i get
like what he's doing
i get what he's doing
i get why it works
and then at that point i walk into that
diner with a gun
and i and i say
hey
how are you
and i grabbed their hand
and they look a little they're like
halfway happy and halfway scared because
they don't know if it's real yet and
neither do i but i just looked at them
and i said i want to let you know we
built this together
and then i blow my brains out
on the diner table
and my brain matter goes in all of their
food because that's what we built
together
that's truly what we built together
okay
that's what we built
the inevitable decay
of our minds and our bodies that we
fight
is coming
the only thing we're building together
is death
truly
and that's what i would say
to those rich
entitled [ __ ]
and by the way thank you for buying
tickets i don't i'm not
i'm just saying
i have a weird relationship with new
york right now
some of it i love i love some of it and
then some of it i just you know
you know it's missing a laurie lightfoot
our mayor bill de blasio is not
uh cartoonish in a funny way
he's not he's just it's just stupid
and it's embarrassing
to bring it
to bring it full circle
you don't have many choices in this
world you don't
there's a few different people you can
be you can be
the limo driver
who gets helped about or you could be
the liar
yelping about the limo driver
there's other options there's other
configurations there's shades in between
but
those are kind of the two i mean it's
the haves and to have nots right i mean
there's disparities sad i don't like it
it's the way it is for the moment things
may change you know
and
you know
you could be the person that says i bet
the official story of 911 is 100 percent
accurate
and by the way if we're not going to
include any of the skepticism uh of the
official narrative in the documentary
what is the documentary again trauma
porn
jerking off to people jumping out of the
buildings yeah talking to the victims
the the families of people that died
gives a [ __ ] about that
who wants to hear that
truly
is there anything new
or are we just going to go on
about the same
nonsense
it is a tragic day and a lot of great
people died and that's [ __ ] horrible
but
i don't know that we need to endlessly
relive it unless we're going to relive
it with a little bit of a cold sober
emotionless look at it but we don't want
that
see the last thing we want is to look at
any of these events without emotion
because then they don't make any sense
you see
you understand
the chaos serves a purpose the chaos is
the point
the chaos is the point the point is not
how did afghanistan get so bad it's the
point
[Laughter]
do you understand
why does lori lightfoot not know what
she's dressing and she's a goon she
knows it's the point
it's the point
what is it what is confusing and
perplexing you
is
the
point
do you understand
what you look at and go why
people
are putting out there
hoping that you are in that state of
confusion panic you don't understand
you're not supposed to understand in
fact
you're not supposed to understand to the
degree that you give up
that you give up
even trying to understand
that's why people's behavior is so
insane and then you go oh wait a minute
teenagers
act out
it's
it's for the purpose of acting out
they want you to be thrown by their
moods their mood swings yes hormonal but
they have control over them but you know
they're like you don't understand me
it's slamming the door and they're goth
one day and they're whatever a stoner
the next day and then they're trying on
all these different identities they
don't know who you are but they just
want attention the point is that
eventually you give up and let them be a
person
that's the point is that eventually you
as a parent go hey she'll figure it out
or he'll figure it out
okay that's the point
that's the point here the chaos
that unfolds
is the actual
point
and when you wrap your head around that
idea
and the media's job
is to sell the chaos like a new
tv show
that has season premieres and season
finales and hooks and reveals
and there's and there's stakes and
there's things that and there's many
moving parts
and it's all
we're all just trying to figure it out
so that things can go back to peace
but we don't want that
we want things
uh the people
the powers that be the idea that like
anybody wants things to make sense ever
again if things made sense
these people would not only be out of a
job many of them would be on death row
truly
so in order for the world to keep going
things
actually can't ever make sense again
ever
so their investment
their investment
is making sure that the leaders have
balloon pants and they're crazy and
they're spectacles and the chaos
is entertaining
and you're watching but you give up
trying to make sense out of it because
that is the biggest threat
making sense
of this nightmare you will then
have the clarity to go wait a
minute
something is rotten
something's very wrong here
but not
if things stay
turbulent
you know in bad turbulence on a flight
you don't go where the [ __ ] my drink
what's going on
bad turbulence you just you you grab the
seat and you pray and you look out the
window and you hope to god that whatever
force is keeping the plane in the air
whatever it is whatever force you want
to call that you hope that that holds up
you hope that that is real
you hope that the thing keeping you
above the ground
exists
you can't see it feel it you don't
understand that you didn't listen in
that class
you don't get it you have a rudimentary
understanding of science morally more
biology because you like googled your
dick but you don't
understand physics or you don't get it
but you're you're hoping you're grabbing
the the the the seat
and and that's the the point we're in
now we're kind of grabbing the seat
and at a certain point in extreme
turbulence you actually give up you'll
actually give up and resign yourself to
death truly and i've talked to people
that have been in bad turbulence where
they go a piece washes over you because
you're getting ready to die you are
getting ready to actually leave your
body you've made peace with it you've
had the moment your life has ran through
your eyes you're you're there and the
plane is pitching and weaving and it's
very very bad and you're looking at the
stewardesses and they're crying
and and and at that moment when you're
on that plane
the only thing that you're gonna be
happy that you did
was said listen [ __ ] we have the
[ __ ] camera the driver never entered
your [ __ ] house
you're a [ __ ] liar
you're gonna be happy you did that
that's the only thing you're gonna be
happy you did
okay
the chaos
is the point
but every now and then
you can even say [ __ ] you to that